the disinfecting team is an action
they're cleaning an entire apartment
block in Hong Kong
it's where the latest coronavirus victim
in the city took ill so all sixteen
floors of the block have to be
sterilized
the playground outside is also sprayed
clean scientists believe the virus could
lay active for up to 72 hours but plenty
of other people are worried and some
hotels and shops are testing
temperatures before guests are allowed
in as China's isolation grows many
Hongkongers are becoming increasingly
incensed about their leaders refusal to
seal the city's borders with the
mainland the Hong Kong government is so
useless she tells us everyone in the
city wants the borders to be locked down
the world should be telling Hong Kong
leaders to close our borders completely
as well as a criss crossing of people
the city is still importing a lot of
live produce from the mainland
without knowing the source of the
outbreak other than the global
coronavirus epicenter is a wet market in
Wuhan like this one which sold seafood
and livestock more border restrictions
are likely to impact on all businesses I
don't agree with the border shutting
down he tells us if we shut down the
border Hong Kong will well the economy
will definitely suffer and we'll end up
with no food to eat them how long seaman
boy yells it there's a lot of dignity no
in shutting up the border you know it's
very difficult for the government
Yaya Yaya and also the people you're
traveling you know also many people you
know they the Stooges you know they are
from the Hong Kong side or for the
millions I know they need to travel a
lot to know so it's very hard for the
government to stop them you know but the
spread of the virus is worrying Hong
Kong is a city thronging with
international travelers and many deeply
distrust the authorities and their
motives I really afraid that I will just
get that disease because this is quite
strong and I feel that the government
didn't like help us enough like getting
masks like stopping the patients are
coming here I learned about like people
are escaping from the hospital so there
is no guarantee they are contouring
inside so there is a danger to our
community here we cannot trust the
government we can the trust does man
named de who come here and they will
sneak out definitely and go and and mix
into our community to this to like
spread the virus
so a city which has been protesting for
months for more democratic rights is
protesting again this time for
protection from the virus and there are
more problems ahead with thousands of
medical staff signing up to join a union
and voting to strike from Monday if all
the border crossings with the mainland
are not shut down the pressure is
building to completely isolate China
Alex Crawford Sky News Hong Kong